What I love about this trip is that
it's an opportunity
to explore places that I haven't
had a chance to explore before.
We are setting out from Toronto,
but we're taking the slow
road up through Muskoka,
cross through Algonquin Park,
through the Ottawa Valley,
and eventually down to Montreal.
The Muskoka Region lends itself
to cranberry growing
because of the acidic soil.
It's a miracle fruit.
I know what you're thinking.
How do I get me one of these?
I grew up in Toronto.
I've seen leaves
and I've appreciated the color,
but this is something
altogether different.
This is a sea of color,
and you can't capture it in any other way
except to stand there and see it for yourself.
You have to make a stop at
Henrietta's Pine Bakery.
It's like the thing to do.
57 years I think they've been
serving up these Muskoka clouds.
Really, really good.
One of the reasons that people
come to Algonquin Park
for the fall colors is the fact that it's so accessible.
There's just nothing like it anywhere else.
Kanatha-Aki means the land without frontier.
My horse, your horse.
In general, our company needs to
reconnect people with the nature, animals.
This is that new bus.
Ok.
You know what makes
this part of the world unique
is that you quickly feel
a part of something.
It was brighter and bolder
than I thought it would be.
There were far more adventures
to be had than I expected.
Incredible culture, fantastic food,
beautiful landscapes.
It's all right here.